[Music]
sophia vergara and joe manganiello just
celebrated their fifth wedding
anniversary
and joe posted this sweet video of their
first dance as husband and wife
to the sinatra classic the way you look
tonight and the way
you look tonight by the way joe's look
is a little different these days
rachel's back from nashville uh joe has
a new due for 2020.
yeah it is kind of hard to miss kev so i
asked joe about his
main makeover and if his wife sophia
approves
what does sophia make of this uh blue
mohawk that you're sporting
i mean you know she married an actor so
she had to she had to think the
weirdness would come out at some point
i got to just say congratulations to you
and sophia that is awesome
five years marriage do you enjoy
yourselves on your anniversary
yeah you know i i courted my wife in new
orleans so
i hired the beignet truck i had them
show up and my wife planned a picnic
so we had a nice time that is so
romantic i love it
how many relationships you've been in
now 2020 it's now been 10 years
since you rose to fame with true blood
what do you remember most
man um those below 20 degree nights
at 4am up in malibu
um standing naked in the middle of a
field that's frosting over
pretending that i'm warm and having a
good time those are the thoughts that
keep me up at night
joe's rocking that mohawk likely for his
return to zack snyder's justice league
but he told us he'll be shaving it off
today when you know that you have to
prepare for a role
how high gear do you cook it in like
what is your
your dedication to working out eating
well it all depends on the character
you know true blood i'm playing a
supernatural character
so um that's how you train you know when
you're doing magic bite if you go to one
of those clubs and you see those guys
they're shredded
they're huge shredded so you know it was
about matching that
you still got them super powers joe's
got a very different
sort of gritty look in arch enemy in
theaters and on demand december 11th
he stars as a homeless alcoholic who
believes he used to have
superpowers it's not a superhero movie
but it's also not
not a superhero movie i read the script
and thought this was one of the craziest
things i've
i've ever read and i have to do this not
only did you star in it though you also
produced it alongside your brother
nick i love my brother uh we we share
the same brain in all the ways with the
same taste so it's
great having a second opinion that i can
[Music]
trust